france l'allocation adulte handicapé de
retour devant le sénat aujourd'hui les
parlementaires vont se prononcer sur son
caractère individuel puisque jusqu'ici
cette aide financière pour incapacité de
travail était uniquement octroyées en
fonction du revenu du foyer une
situation de dépendance de fait
vis-à-vis du conjoint qui a été dénoncée
à de nombreuses reprises par beaucoup
d'associations et pour en parler
justement on va retrouver alain prunier
et vice président de la fédération
nationale des accidentés du travail et
des handicapés
[Musique]
alain premier bonjour bonjour merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation ce
matin alors on le disait le texte sur
l'individualisation de l'allocation aux
adultes handicapés en couple aujourd'hui
devant le sénat alors pour bien
comprendre ce dont vous voulez vous
détacher vous aujourd'hui finalement
c'est la situation de dépendance
vis-à-vis du conjoint c'est bien cela
c'est exactement cela aujourd'hui le
calcul de l'allocation aux adultes
handicapés dépend des ressources du
ménage ce qui fait que moi en patois
environ 300000 personnes ne bénéficient
pas de l'allocation adulte handicapé à
taux plein bientôt seul mois torodi
voire pas du tout et tel type de
difficultés cette loi engendrait
concrètement
6 bat pour le gouvernement cette fois
gendron aurait des difficultés
il prétexte que le syli accorder ce
droit à l'allocation de vue quant à
l'allocation aux adultes handicapés
pardon il faudrait qu'il accorde
également à d'autres prestations telles
que la location le rsa l'allocation de
solidarité spécifique et autres
romanciers bien évidemment mais c'est
lorsqu'il n'est pas nous on veut pas que
soit évoqué les questions financières
pour le calcul de la hache et très
concrètement est ce que ça veut dire que
lorsqu'on est une personne en situation
de handicap
eh bien on refuse de vivre en couple
pour ne pas perdre finalement une
allocation c'est des choses qui arrivent
oui c'est des choses qui peuvent arriver
et qui se passe quand même marginale
moi je connais pas je n'ai jamais
rencontré de personnes qui refusaient d
habillement couple au motif que le
conjoint avait des ressources et que
cela entraînerait une diminution de
l'âge voire une suppression mais c'est
en théorie c'est une situation qui bien
évidemment peu existé et il n'y a pas de
raison que la personne handicapée soit
dépendante de son conjoint pour
l'appréciation de ces ressources la
personne handicapée à ne pas sur ma
dépendance comme plus de personnes en
france donc il n'y a aucune raison qui
justifie cette dépendance du col des
revenus du conjoint pour le calcul de sa
de la prestation qui est versée
comment le fait que ce soit attaché à
son conjoint quel type de défigurer
sacré concrètement dans les foyers est
sacrée que la personne handicapée est
dépendante de son conjoint ce qui peut
entraîner des situations conflictuelles
notamment des situations que connaissent
aujourd'hui des femmes cadres
couple s'est il est tout à fait anormal
et un est aujourd'hui inacceptable que
quelqu'un a des preuves des ressources
d'un autre pour pour vivre donc là
maintenant ça va dans le bon sens selon
vous
serra dans le bon sens non puisque le
gouvernement a refusé le gouvernement a
refusé l'assemblée nationale a également
refusé que c'est à refuser l'évolution
de cette législation aujourd'hui ça va
ça vient devant le sénat qui normalement
quand plus de la majorité du sénat
devrait devrait approuver vision
approuvé cette mesure mais en seconde
lecture à l'assemblée nationale au pire
en confirmant rare malheureusement c'est
ce refus
que nous contestons bien évidemment en
juin dernier le gouvernement avait
privilégié une formule jugée plus
redistributive un abattement forfaitaire
de
2 5 milles euros sur le
revenu du conjoint qu'est ce que vous en
pensez pourquoi ça vous convient pas
finalement cette cette formule
cette formule convient mais va toucher
très peu de personnes en définitive
merci beaucoup j'imagine que vous allez
suivre attentivement évidemment
les auditions au sénat sur sur cette
proposition de loi donc merci beaucoup
alain brunier d'avoir répondu ce matin
en direct à nos questions sur rt france